the stories this is nuts Chinese
retailers ban popular nintendo game
animal crossing new horizons after
players use it to organize virtual
protests against Xi Jinping and the
World Health Organization there were
some other stories too where it claimed
that it was like what were they calling
it like a an absent absent of authority
or something no in a vacuum of authority
a vacuum of authority yeah so I don't
know if this huh this has something to
do with what was going on in Minecraft
remember that story it was like these
journalists created an archive within
minecraft people can access in the
virtual world yeah it's amazing but now
apparently they're gonna start banning
games now here's here's my theory I
think this could be a precursor to a
major international conflict if they're
banning it's like a memos or something
right you know the gist of the story was
it's talked about Animal Crossing and
retailers yeah there's a another article
yeah Animal Crossing got banned well
it's it's theirs they go in to talk
about how it's pretty much any any
public multiplayer game where people can
talk that they can't censor or observe
so the main thing is Animal Crossing
because it just came out so it's like a
huge new game that's that's multiplayer
so now they're able to like you could
see this article right here you know it
says right over set free Hong Kong so
it's like oh yeah yeah you know it's a
free Hong Kong Revolution now so that
that's like the world that he named his
world that so anyone that goes into his
world is like and they see that like oh
okay I could go into that world cuz I
think that too let's go in there and
chat so I don't think it's international
I think it's China trying to shut down
any sort of like a coup for like a civil
war from their own citizens finally
going we've had enough because I'm
seeing these videos emerge from China
but this guy's not from China is he he's
in Hong Kong hey let me let me read this
they say right right no official reason
for the removal was given but activist
Joshua Wong of the Hong Kong youth
movement demo seat so Sisto said the
decision was caused by protests
activities he and others had conducted
in the game he said oh no xi Jinping
banned animal crossing in China
apparently because I play it and these
angry gamers are blaming me everywhere
instead of blaming their own government
according to a report from a ping West
public I'm sorry from pink West public
chat groups dedicated to the game on
WeChat had also adopted new rules to
prevent discussion of the ban and were
removing any members who tried to bring
it up the game is set on a small cartoon
island and asked players to help a
quirky cast of anthropomorphic animal
residents with errands and chores while
gradually raising money and collecting
items to build out their home well I
think most of us you that's that's the
gist of Animal Crossing it is a foofy
fun family game yeah but I think I
disagree with you Adam he the it sounds
like he's saying this active is saying
that the Chinese people don't like him
they're not blaming the government for
the running him for it
hmm what worries me about this is that
through online gaming you have
communication with people in a foreign
country so you have like that that
archive and minecraft if they start
banning online games because of things
people are saying outside of China right
then they're segmenting their population
from communicating with the rest of the
world there's already the great Chinese
firewall they've already tried to do
that try doing this
Russia has apparently tried doing this
what ends up happening in my opinion is
if you have the government saying the
United States government did this and
then someone goes online and they speak
with an American who says well here's
what here's what we heard then there's
doubt right you can't rally your public
to support your cause if they're getting
information from the other side well but
in that same sense they can't convince
their you know their public that it's
America's fault
if they're mad at the CCP like Chinese
citizens are mad at the CCP and they're
blaming them and the CCP is like no no
it's America like we're just trying to
stop you from you know believing what
you you're saying it's us but it's not
it's America and then they're doing
exactly that they're going in these
forums and going oh yeah but these
American friends of mine are like that's
not what's going but they're bad in the
forums they're blocking people right to
make sure that their citizens think what
they're telling them so right it could
go either way honestly both both things
could be true but it it feels like
they're just trying this as a tactic for
control they're just trying to maintain
the narrative they want their citizens
to get everything from them and take
anything that
could get outside source information and
take it away I'll tell tell you this
we've seen the video of the people
riding at the Wuhan border mm-hmm you
remember that thing yeah yeah so so
those aren't familiar they like flipped
over a squad car yeah van or something
and and the Wuhan Police were with them
yeah yeah fighting the outside forces
this way I don't like the idea of the
bio lab conspiracy theory that I'm sorry
the bio weapon conspiracy theory yeah I
don't know cuz this might destabilize
China I think it will I think that's
exactly what's happening there they're
losing control and they're communists so
they they have to have the controller's
it doesn't work absolutely if their
citizens are there if it's bubbling up I
feel it is because we've seen these
videos we've seen people in China
fighting like the police state and what
what you got to realize when we see
videos in the u.s. of people smashing
cop cars and setting fires yeah like
dude we're a country based on protests
and unruliness it's true we literally
told the king to go shove it mm-hmm
and then we're like it's our country now
hey so we protest is what we do like I'm
not saying it's good when people ride
and stuff I'm just saying come on man
Americans we ride for everything
football game we won riot and we lose
riot also riot in China they don't in
China you you put the wrong post on the
internet and they torture you yeah like
that we seen that video of the guy being
tortured by the cops and they're like
why did you make fun of us so the risk
for the Chinese to protest seems I'm not
an expert on China okay I know there's a
lot of you know Pro China people who
like to rag on me assuming that I think
I am I'm not but I've seen videos of
people like some woman put a camera in
her room she had turned her phone on and
then police come in and like take her
away and she filmed it like you say the
wrong thing they come for you so imagine
what these people must have been
thinking when I started flipping over a
police vehicle they didn't care anymore
you know they were like nothing you
could do to me is worse than what's
already happening exactly and I think
that that's happening right now yeah
take away someone's video game that's
the final straw yes that's why I dropped
but wasn't Trump talking about football
and he was lying
we all miss sports but he was saying
something about like you can't take away
someone's football like it's got a
startup we're talking with the the
sports companies yeah all of them he's
he's you know bringing all of the
experts not
experts the owners basically look at
look at the Roman Colosseum at least the
way it's portrayed and like you know
fictional narratives or whatever that
was basically a distraction for the
people yeah I think it's really funny
they say like oh they had all these
problems in Rome but they would come out
and throw bread to the to the audience
and they would watch these games and it
would keep them say she ated it mm-hmm
we got we got like four Coliseum's in
every major city basically yeah now
right now here's the thing I always
thought about this I'm like man most
these people don't care about was going
on in the world because they care more
about their hometown team versus you
know the other team their rival what
happens when the sport stops yeah all of
a sudden people's team becomes political
now the government is probably thinking
we need people to watch football I
definitely think that definitely because
they probably are looking at China going
whoa man well the whole ting over there
right now because Sports has been frozen
these sports is taking center stage
that's good because people can still
play games online that's true
China has just I'm doing is now banning
some of these video games right so I'll
tell you I man what are you gonna do now
you can you can keep your population you
know in the corner in the dark just like
not paying attention because they're
staring at the screen pressing buttons
and harvesting little digital flowers
take that away from them they're gonna
look up and ask what just happened and
why yeah this is a stupidest thing they
could have done it's like you you you've
you've given people it's almost like you
give a dog a treat yeah I never try and
take it back he growls at you yeah like
he didn't care about it before but not
he's got it you don't take it away from
him so in that regard not only are they
distracted but you've given them
something that's that's that's appeased
to them they've grown addicted to it you
take that away
they're not gonna protest because of
your authoritarian abuses they're gonna
protest because you took away their
video game like you've created a reason
for a revolution yeah
no I mean I'm not gonna I mean the
reason was there but but now like I'm
saying it's a different reason no no
it's just the final straw you put it up
there and it finally breaks the camel's
back
well no no it's I mean I said you're
saying but the point I'm trying to make
is if they never had the games in the
first place hmm they'd be doing
something else
okay but when you give them this game
yeah and just came out and like that
last week and now they're all like
others so fun now take it away from them
now they know how good that how good it
was and they're mad they
lost it yeah so not only do they have
the reason to protest or revolt because
of like the border closures the
continued suspension of like you know
business and everything now you've taken
away what little reprieve they had in
the first place
so I don't know look I mean whether or
not it translates to internal conflict I
think there's a good argument because
people like they're you know novelties
but my bigger concern is with the
actions we've seen from the Chinese
government could this contribute to a
separation between the Chinese people
and people outside of China which then
creates an obedient and you know angry
population which rallies behind their
government and then the government says
oh you know we banned this because the
Americans are about putting propaganda
on disinformation a lot of people gonna
believe it
then what happens right now if China
comes out and says the u.s. just sank
our carrier welcome imagine if they
faked it like that can that carrier they
brought out to the ocean it's like yeah
we everybody is seeing it go out there
and then they're like oh the America's
sunk it I would be insane so these
things have happened false flags like
the Gulf of Tonkin incident
what if China did that their people
would not know and so they're all
frantic in back oh no we're being
attacked by the Americans oh no I guess
were then yeah yeah so it's funny
because a lot of a lot of the conspiracy
theories we hear about false flags are
typically the u.s. u.s. citizens talk
about the US government so I think I
don't know the full details of the Tova
Tonkin incident it got us pulled into
the Vietnam War right but it was a it
was apparently like fake they said like
a u.s. ship was attacked and never was
or something like that I don't know the
full details you have to you can look it
up but it's funny because we never
talked about other governments doing the
same thing and that's why I'm concerned
when they start cutting off
communication which China's been doing
for a long time you know it creates the
opportunity for them to lie to their
people and rally them to you know
basically support militaristic actions
against other countries yeah exactly
yeah did you find it yeah apparently it
was kind of a false flag they found
something they called Tonkin ghosts
which were false radar images they were
not actually North Vietnamese torpedo
boats
well they claimed the ship got hit right
yeah didn't yeah so one of the what okay
so one of the aircraft was damaged one
real and one falsely claimed
confrontation between
nor us look so much goes on at top
secret levels we'll never know yeah but
I know could you imagine living in a
country that took away your video games
no the internet definitely not no keep
your people I would riot you keep your
people fat and happy man I love games
I'm always been a gamer so there push it
hard and people are already riled up
it's me so I guess we'll see how this
you know I don't know pans out yeah I
guess so thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you